so we had a question on we will use it
to explain more to you from Five Points
of
the tactics involved in Ikea's growth
okay
so you have what we would do as chemo
and it kind of misleads you
if you make the mistake that that's how
the technique shows up tastic that's a
kihon waza okay it's like a coded
message for all kinds of things
um but it's taxable application is not
a one-to-one code you gotta look deeper
than that okay
um
so where does it show up
uh we'll do it first from
uh you'll get Tony okay so let's say I'm
going to throw into the front kazushi
the front inward kazushi okay
and the guy
really hangs on to his balance okay now
stay there
the the energy of the throw is going
this way
okay
and what ends up happening and we not
only does his body
uh is going to spin on that centrifugal
energy
but just his body alone the way that his
mass is set up if he takes that hand
ground uh don't try not to roll try to
stay in place and leave your leg high
and you'll see don't follow what you'll
see that that leg is gonna is gonna
start to eventually spin out if you need
to use me for some base but don't hold
on yeah you see that leg starts to go
that way okay and you can run that
experiment on your own you just you just
gets here and eventually that leg will
go to the outside
is a
state so uh a guy that is trying to pull
eventually that leg will go out and it's
gonna be kind of hard uh to demonstrate
but let's see what happens okay so
trying to resist to throw as much as off
that step okay
yeah
foreign
so imagine we'll slow down and we'll
start to see that so that when that leg
is gonna get around
so yeah it'll be like that okay it's not
going to be
in the front inward kazushi so I'll show
you if you pay attention it's gonna be
on the back side
of that leg okay
you know what I'm saying and all you got
to do is Chuck someone and there it is
every time so it's where for example
the sweeps are in that same place okay
um
that little thing all right let's let's
get there bye
[Music]
geometrically so uh the guys coming in
and then we're trying for that and then
what he does is he goes ahead and
sacrifices this balance position okay he
in essence he's going with the energy
you see that's what he's doing and so if
you look for uh where it tends to come
off is
um you were trying to do a momentum
throw
and the guy does not fall off the regain
their balance okay and you you held on
to their arm or something like that so
if you pay attention like in in this
version we come around here
it's doing the same thing
you're in that key mode okay or even in
the the basic kihon when when you come
around like that right uh from where I'm
at he's it say then his stance is in
that same thing that leg is behind the
front leg and you see the sweep is
from this side home
that leg is it that back leg is in front
of his leg
can you see that
can you see it okay but as soon as I go
like that there it is so I'll show just
to show you uh I'm gonna move that leg
back
okay and I slide them around and I
thought behind him do you see it moved
that way the key on is is doing that
same thing right from where I'm at
but what you want to know is when you're
doing front inward positions a guy can
sacrifice
his orientation towards you and put get
that foot there
okay you got it and it will come up more
than not in live situations where you
did a momentum truck okay the way you
get out of it in your is with your
cookie projection that foot does not get
to stay there you see that but in a
momentum throat you go to do it and he
can do it
okay
in the projection throw that foot does
not
and that's why he can't counter that
throat okay but it happens a lot in live
situations
uh especially if you don't have the
projection skills okay so uh we're going
here we'll do that momentum throw and
that's where it is
okay that's where your shimogaga is
there's something to note though
uh in the keyhorn
he's allowed to stay straight you see he
even if he turns a little he's pretty up
um back here so we can keep the
orientation
and this
this slice
it would be able for him to do that
it's because this hand tends to cut down
so you're going and you're going to see
that his head is down when he does that
see now it makes no sense and this is
the second thing it makes no sense to
bring them back up
okay
so we'll do the keyhon
and I'm going to set up that stance
there it is okay
and in the keyhand you kind of do bring
him up
but we want to pay attention to
something in the keyhon that helps
a little bit more
okay I am going to not
turn
I'm going to come across
I'll do those two versions
okay
cool
that's it I'll just keep it with the
motel so mote I go in then I turn
then I entered again
is where
I keep my Center this way I step across
there's
same beginning but I step across there
it goes
there's no current can you see that I'll
do the other one
answer Turner there's none of that
Pizza Hut in front of you
oh it's okay
okay let's get there we have all those
other videos I'm not gonna go into the
like the grip game okay I'll just
quickly say here your shimanaga is not
on the forearm it doesn't work because
you do not have the mechanical advantage
don't hurt me uh he has the mechanical
advantage okay
um he can just pull down on his elbow
and I can never hold that okay but once
I get to the wrist do you see and I turn
that more and now he does not have a
mechanical advantage because the smaller
joint is working against him so uh if we
you could even have them higher as he
tries to pull his elbow it makes his
balance go because it goes into his
wrist so you cannot do it here you
should never do it here this is you're
you're fooling yourself okay I don't
care how high it is put your elbow
really high it's you don't have the
leverager he's basically doing a thumb
lock on you which is why in Sim similar
situations in your nawaza this would be
thumbless grip so you don't expose the
thumb to it okay
um
going on
why
don't we want him standing like that
you see this is upright or I get in
slightly tilted and then I come around
and he stands up again there do you see
do you see that right okay
um well let's go back to where it tends
to open up you tried the front end where
the kazishi is not in that position
and two
anytime
uh your guy is standing up for any
joints any joint lock so let's do Nico
because everyone loves Nico do you think
and every you're usually in Aikido
they'll show this to new people to
convince them how Marshall the art is
because they'll go like this ah
and because they're egocentric it hurt
me and I'm the center of the universe
your art must be real okay that's all
the lock is functioning because the UK
did not move their feet
no one told them not to but they just
don't okay any joint manipulation
requires that force be stabilized
otherwise
the articulatable
[Music]
joints will take away your leverage okay
so for example if I leave my feet here
and he does the lock it's gonna work
okay if I move my feet
it does not work now it's off do it do
you see and he would have to turn to put
it back on
he'll put it back on do you see
but what can I do so he tries to put it
on I change the joint manipulation the
the angles of the articulation he moves
and I move
they're saying it it'll never stop you
get that so your techniques have ways of
stopping them
and the way is
their body is trapped within an inertial
path
you can't reverse it do you get that
okay so
the only way I keep them tracking the
inertial path is not let them Bop off
that's taking them out of the inertial
path and now he has full mobility and
the joint The Joint lock or the joint
manipulation will not work so we go and
as long as I keep my feet here go and he
does she who knock it it is going to
work that leverage thing that I just
told you is going to work okay
but if I move my feet
even when he's here you see and I moved
to here it's not going to work now so
even that little hand leverage thing
right if I just keep moving my feet it
won't work
so my body has to be preoccupied
and it can't be straight up because then
it is Back in Balance it now has
Mobility do you get that and the
resisting person will not be there okay
so
when you come into this technique this
little tilt that I have in the keyhorn I
am going to keep
I'm going to keep that tilt look try to
see where his body is
his body's going this way
okay
so I'm gonna move myself
so that it will will make okay keep
going that way I'm gonna move myself so
that I capture
there okay where is there
there is that sweet spot he goes
where your compliant new kid did not
move their feet do you see that if you
get shihonage and I don't move my feet
he's got you okay butterfly he doesn't
have me anymore so you have to replicate
that but now in motion so you have to
kind of think
he's going this way
he's gone around me
so I move
so I catch him there
you see that
and raw
another way of looking at it
is he he stays in that tilt
I don't stand back around
today
okay let's try
some other things so the other mistake
is you pick him up
beginner mistake
you're on this foreign
[Music]
he has too much Leverage
I don't have any leverage even even if
I'm on the hand it's very difficult to
keep this leverage okay which is why if
he steps back
He's Able more to lower his elbow do you
see and I lose leverage as we go okay
it doesn't change if you put his elbow
here
on the side and you have like some kind
of shoulder elbow lock it doesn't take
much for him to pull that don't hurt me
again these just put your elbow
underneath here is that okay
no no no
body has to be up the elbow has to be up
which means his Center has to be forward
okay you can't get his elbow up
with his centered knot forward which
won't happen when he's straight it's
parallel pretty much and it's very easy
for him to pull down you'll lose
leverage okay
so keep that all in mind as you're doing
the this like Dad don't have his elbow
look
it's parallel can you see from behind me
or no
no is it it's parallel that's not gonna
work
so his elbow is gonna go up do you see
it going up
you see that
I I have the intention
of getting his elbow to go
okay
another beginner mistake is uh he's
gonna go
right and then reaction right and then I
turn I can turn like this you see how my
hips turn that way you see that but in
the technique is which way were my hips
going my hips going this way do you
understand
so usually the way that happens but you
want to pay attention to it is uh you
are not controlling their center with it
being preoccupied on an inertial path so
uh maybe on your on your Keyhole they're
just standing still do you see and then
you come around like that and now he
could turn it into that you could turn
his hips into that technique and take
that front brake off or maybe you did
initially occupy their Center but then
you gave it back to him now he could
turn into it you see so
his energy is going to be preoccupied
this way which would stop it from
turning this way okay but you can do
your lock in in a way that you actually
have a lock this is where that wrist
comes in handy where the forearm does
not okay the the wrist stops him
from turning that way do you see that it
adds it adds a kind of ashness to it
okay and uh the more he tries to turn
his his that way it goes into the lock
okay
so as you're coming around again another
reason not to be on the forearm because
it won't allow you to control his hips
he can turn his hips and then he'll take
your beautiful front brake ball
but the bad guy will escape the bad guy
will move their feet and pull their
elbow down and continue the attack okay
so you really want to right here you're
on the wrist already you already have a
footage you see and that stops his wrist
from turning around from turning into
Center stops the center
that gets that leg in the back and then
this chair stops him from uh turning
into them
okay so get on that wrist another reason
well I want to make sure that you
understand what happens if he does if he
gives me my center it's not occupied
with the inertial path going in the
opposite direction and if he does not
have uh my Center through where he's
touching such that
I'm able to turn do you see for my nice
break fall of what when I said that the
bad guy would not be there what I mean
is since I have so much control in my
Center you see I could just continue my
attack because I'm gonna neutralize all
the joint control he has because I'm
moving those joints in space you
understand okay so let's go back uh to
generating that kind of new Cami you see
and we're going to uh take a more
advantage of this tilt that he's in
we're going to even reduce it less okay
uh it doesn't matter we'll just do it
some uh throws
you know there we go
[Music]
right there
don't don't let me break your mind
all right
[Music]
by not going up and dropping underneath
he does not come up
even more
[Music]
foreign
it's all right
so I'm not having to do anything
with his body
[Music]
as you guys see he's a virtually
occupied okay
okay
try hey all right so if I'm doing your
commands so he's got your promise and he
can't start he can't start from out
there who he has he's in my kicking
range you got it so he's got to get into
strike to raise right okay so he does
his thing and here's that same
beginning okay
so he goes off I hit it oh cool he fell
but
[Music]
right oh there you have it right there
right
[Music]
okay let's try it from Yoku uh so I did
it from uh ryota Tony it's it's really a
failed front inward to Sushi and the guy
challenged it okay not sure not yet
opening is
um
when you're doing the the your command
right I'm not uh trying to get his arm
and spin him around right uh here's the
end
his hand goes up boom contact and then
I'm inside of that strike and I have my
ik adhesion till I get that elbow and
then the yoka man is going over the top
you see that
is not a lifesaver
so you are taking this balance I don't
swear you're hitting around and then he
counters that and that's where your
Shield will not get it
he's got to give that openly okay
try it again it's not your job to spin
him around
do you see that you can't catch strikes
like that you cannot catch the stripes
you can't block them either
you blend with the disliker sword work
okay let's go
okay so a question came up in our
trading they weren't understanding it
and they went back to the goofy Aikido
culture Okay so uh here we are we're
we're doing now the strike and you're
getting this kind of stuff you see and
uh the person swings around so let me
use you because just do what you did
that he comes around and the person
swings around you see and they keep
walking they keep walking around do you
understand
keep walking around me
can you just do
it you're gonna do it again just walk
around me walk around me walk around
with
you that is not the opening okay that is
not the opening the opening was
on a failed Kohinoor
or any technique that is going to the
front inward kazushi pattern okay
in order for them
to become
unprojectable they're going to
disconnect their Center
do you understand that okay uh so
if you pay attention
and she's doing the strike
his body is nowhere as organized you see
that
now try not to fall down
you see now we've got organized but one
little Shuffle back tiny little Shuffle
it's not organized it's twisted if you
pay attention
organize yourself again
you see now he's got a strong homologo
side to him
when he is Twisted
uh I'm not sure you even understand sir
I'm like this
you see as opposed to like this so
instead of here
I'm like this
there's a Twist to my body which is what
freed me freed my center from the
kokunage so lock my body he's gonna
project me but I'm gonna disconnect it
you see this corner fell out right and
as this leg now is not going to come
around
into pirouette
it's gonna come around boom like that
you see and I'm twisted again
that is
okay
if I do this and a person would
pirouette that's Twisted go back in a
perfect pirouette this is when you take
the box and you do something like
open
here she's twisting there it is right
there
[Music]
do you have to look for that
when you have a new kid who will not
twist for you it's because you did not
do the kokunaga and they did not counter
it you did this thing
they come around perfectly
homo laterally aligned
okay
so all you have to do
is
get the energy going Moon there's the
twist right there that's where I come in
okay
try out